[Music]
respond Fox 3
then I'm wanted
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know I'm going to blow your head
off
monsters exist yesterday I was a
crackpot but today you dropped those
charges to flush something out who are
you
ancient species on this earth long
before mankind and if we keep our heads
buried in the sand they will take it
back my agency is known as monarch we
specialized in the hunt for massive
unidentified terrestrial organisms can
leave that thing without here I'm sorry
for your men colonel
I truly am get us home with proof so we
can send the cavalry
these are photos of an island in the
South Pacific the place where myth and
science me
we use explosives to shake the earth
helping us to map the surface of the
island you're dropping bombs scientific
instruments
and then I'm walking
magnificent
you knew that thing was out here I'm
sorry for your man Colonel but if you
want to make this sacrifice worthwhile
get us home with proof monsters exist
[Music]
your friend there can put that down what
the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comes
pretty good King keeps himself mostly
well you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight with cones God on the
island but the Devils live below us
and what are they called I call them
skull crawlers why never said that name
out loud before it sounds stupid now
that I say just you call them whatever
you want
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here
well look at that it breathes
we did that hookup with gentlemen
there's enough munitions on their down
sea stallion to finish the job
like nificent no why I carry this
instead of an m16 took it off a farmer
fighting for the NVA he surrendered
right after we leveled his village he
was 50 years old said he never even seen
a gun till we showed up sometimes an
enemy doesn't exist
do you're looking for one what happens
when they show up on your doorstep I
still have his gun that's the luck with
that soldier
[Music]
Kohn's god on the island an ancient
species on this earth long before
mankind
we're going to bring that tape down
we don't belong here we're going to safe
Kong
come Skull Island rated pg-13 experience
it in IMAX March 10th this is a
satellite photo of an uncharted island
in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science meet
Kong has been rican sieved as a myth
come to life you can't be looking for a
dragon who all was a my tracking
the island isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
you don't go into someone's house and
start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission
I became they have he was my white whale
we're very happy to say that we have the
biggest Kong of them all
he is truly monstrous in size and scale
and scope when people step foot on this
island
the first visceral response is to look
at that thing and say that's a god
that's the big one
this film will be an immersive spectacle
calm skal island has things you haven't
seen before it takes you to a different
world where things are beautiful and
terrifying all at the same time
it's huge and we're talking about one of
the greatest myths of all time
this is a satellite photo of an
uncharted island in the South Pacific
a place where myth and science need
Kong has been rican sieved as a myth
come to life
this film will be an immersive spectacle
he got Kong that's a hundred feet tall
it really has to be seen in IMAX the
whole movie just gets taken to the next
level Washington IMAX
you really just lose yourself what the
hell is this place
it tells this incredible story of man
versus nature you came here looking for
a track n who old was am i tracking I've
been looking for this island for years
get us home with proof monsters exist
the island isn't just a place that looks
specifically like one thing as you
continue to travel through it you see
the variations it's never been touched
you don't know what to expect like any
natural jungle there are predators
go into someone's house and start
dropping bombs unless you're picking a
fight
Kong is killing his men so it becomes
his mission that man is king he's not an
animal he's not a beast he's a being and
it's just something that we don't
understand yet he is truly monstrous in
size and scale high schoo when people
step foot on this island their first
visceral response just look at that
thing and say that's a god that's the
big one
I hope the film inspires Wanda and/or
Kong Skull Island takes you to a
different world where things are
beautiful and terrifying all at the same
time it's IMAX and it's 3d it's huge and
we're talking about one of the greatest
myths of all time
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here you should
come here you came here looking for a
tracker who or what am i tracking
that's the big one
before we leave this island we're going
to bring that eight down I'm gonna die
together out here Skull Island
rated pg-13 experienced at a 9 X which
tends
[Music]
yeah they smell that that's death
what the hell is this place this is
what's left of Khan's pants
I've taken enough photos of mass graves
to recognize one crash sites just on the
other side it's Valley will cross
through and make it to the highest point
west
uh-huh this place is a real nono sir
we need to be going to the north side
right now and you welcome to do that my
man by yourself not leaving Jack out
there there who's with me we can make it
mighty right we can make enough space
sharp keep an eye out
I've only been here 28 years where do I
time to show that man is king
Kong Skull Island rated pg-13 experience
it in IMAX March Jen's it's a survey job
just chopper them in and out be a
joyride
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know
I'm gonna blow your head off
[Music]
this planet doesn't belong to us
[Music]
each species owned deserve long before
mankind
I spent 30 years trying to prove the
truth monsters exist
you don't go into someone's house unless
you're picking a fight
what you're looking at is a monster from
some bygone era
it's trying to show Batman
it's good
the Kong has been rican sieved as a myth
come to life
this film will be an immersive spectacle